hey little liars Liana galera here with
the original a the lovely Janel Parrish
we're here to talk about the new text
message tormentor yes it is threatening
the girls five years later evil emojis
coming your way emojis yeah Holly yes
this this new situation this uber a is
actually going to be even more dangerous
than me or Charlotte so yeah we've got
we've got more twists and turns in true
Pretty Little Liars fashions in your way
do you think that Mona has it in her to
do it again could she be uber a I think
Mona has it in her to do anything Mona
wants to do that's the interesting thing
about that character and that's why it's
so fun for me to play because she she
can do anything she puts her mind to
she's extremely smart she's very sneaky
we all know what she's capable of and
you never really quite know what her
motives are just out of curiosity who
kisses better Hanna Spencer or me now
let's switch gears a little bit and jump
aboard the ships of the show the ships
because we plan I switched it up we've
had some shipping shake-up you know
Caleb I know you will with Hannah now
he's a Spencer I will save my opinion I
have Olivia my opinion I I got she'd
been pretty open about house on Twitter
I'm not for it really reason why is
because I'm a huge Caleb san-craig I
love Haleb I think there's such a sweet
couple and their chemistry on camera is
just amazing and so when I heard that it
was gonna be Spencer and Caleb I was
like no it's supposed to be with Hannah
it's meant to be they've been through so
much so I'm I'm rooting for halo
you